[Musique]
j'ai eu une très très grande dispute
avec mon père pendant une soirée et sa
phrase a été ça ne va pas tu te casses
et donc j'ai préféré on va dire partir
en urgence
ma famille mes amis tout
mon travail aussi comme j'étais en
apprentissage j'ai tout perdu le milieu
son relativement c'est fermé
la chaîne et on subit ça au quotidien et
on le subit encore
[Musique]
on a des jeunes qui arrivent avec juste
un sac à dos qu'on vécu pas mal de
violences il y a encore des situations
d'exclusion et voir des fois des parents
qui prennent en otage leur enfant lui
prennent le téléphone n'empêche de
sortir l'oblige à envoyer des messages
des SMS violents à son petit ami ou à sa
petite amie
être exclu rejeté de sa famille à cause
de son orientation sexuelle furent un
foyer un village pour survivre en 2023
cela existe toujours impossible de
savoir chaque année combien de jeunes se
retrouvent obligés de partir
rémi a connu cela agit aujourd'hui de 23
ans et installé à Lille il a quitté sa
famille en quelques heures son calvaire
a commencé à l'adolescence au moment
d'évoquer son homosexualité à ses
proches
originaire de Vichy dans l'Allier il a
pris un jour un billet de train pour
être accueilli en urgence par l'antenne
du refuge basé à Angers
dans ma famille de ça en fait mon coming
out je l'ai fait à ma belle-mère et
c'est ma belle-mère qui a voulu dire à
mon père comme elle connaissait la
réaction de mon père en fait tu lui as
dit
après que je l'annonça à mon père on
s'est pas parlé pendant plusieurs mois
c'était pas de bonjour pour dormir on
prenait pas la voiture ensemble on dit
n'est pas ensemble il a vécu à la rue
dormi chez des amis a connu la
dépression et des tentatives de suicide
puis il a contacté le refuge structure
venant en aide aux personnes dans son
cas
du jour au lendemain on arrive dans une
nouvelle ville avec des accueillis par
des personnes que je connais pas du tout
il nous donne l'amour qu'on a plus c'est
de l'accompagnement psychologie
médicale aussi on peut se reprendre en
fait
renaître être accompagné pour démarrer
une nouvelle vie c'est ce que propose le
refuge il dispose d'une vingtaine
d'antenne dans toute la France dans ce
local lillois de la structure un espace
de dialogue avec une travailleuse
sociale les jeunes accueillis
bénéficient d'aide dans toutes leurs
démarches
il y a beaucoup de choses qui avance
quand même
harmonie vine suite individuellement
toutes les personnes accueillies par le
refuge un rôle multiple un
accompagnement sur différents terrains
médicaux sociaux ou encore professionnel
on a des jeunes qui sont très isolés où
il y a pas eu de suivi médical depuis
longtemps où il y a une rupture scolaire
aussi parfois avec des situations de
harcèlement la priorité pour eux c'est
d'avoir quelqu'un en face qui les écoute
parfois on a tendance nous en tant que
travailleur sociaux à vouloir
solutionner tous les problèmes mais il y
a un temps d'adaptation qui est
nécessaire un temps d'écoute qui est
nécessaire et ça fait beaucoup pour le
jeûne qui l'a pas forcément eu depuis un
certain moment le refuge c'est aussi un
local un espace pour se retrouver
emprunter des livres discuter
on a ici le vestiaire où on entrepose
des vêtements propres quand les jeunes
arrivent ils peuvent se servir librement
et ensuite ici on a un petit salon
convivial on a une télévision des jeux
Rémi fait partie de l'équipe des
bénévoles il réalise des collectes pour
aider les personnes accueillies
on leur fournit un kit d'arrivée avec
des serviettes dentifrice brosse à dents
gel douche et sont déjà vécu moult
aventure péripéties
et tout ce qu'on peut avoir apporté nous
les bénévoles c'est le réconfort des
produits de la nourriture la nourriture
ça fait du bien
et ici tu as la plus grande et voici
l'un des futurs logements du refuge les
jeunes accueillis étant parfois victimes
de harcèlement ou de menaces la
localisation de ses habitations est
tenues secrètes la structure propose
actuellement 13 places d'hébergement sur
l'île une centaine de personnes ont été
accueillies depuis 10 ans il y a de plus
en plus de demandes donc de plus en plus
de difficultés je dirais le côté positif
c'est que les jeunes maintenant
osent de plus en plus nous appeler mais
en même temps effectivement on a besoin
de plus en plus de place d'hébergement
parce que l'homophobie la transphobie
qu'on perdure et augmente
le refuge sollicite des bailleurs
sociaux pour pouvoir disposer de ses
logements c'est la seule structure de ce
genre existant dans tous les routes
France alors que les demandes
d'hébergement sont croissantes depuis la
création du refuge en France 3000
personnes ont été hébergées une
structure a même été ouverte en Belgique
pays pourtant très progressiste et qui
n'a jamais réprimé les relations
homosexuelles même si l'exclusion frappe
toutes les catégories sociales certains
milieux sont particulièrement concernés
ça touche de plus en plus des jeunes qui
sont issus de famille déjà précaires au
précarisés j'ai l'impression
effectivement et avec le recul avec
l'expérience que les familles je dirais
de classe moyenne
rejette moins leur enfant ou que les
jeunes trouvent des solutions
intermédiaires par le biais des études
par le biais de l'Université du CROUS on
a souvent un taux de demande plus élevé
durant les regroupements familiaux
c'est-à-dire à Noël à Pâques et
effectivement le confinement les
familles se sont retrouvées entre elles
donc il y a eu effectivement une forte
demande
des propos et comportements homophobes
qui se multiplient depuis quelques
années de quoi mener à l'exclusion
il y a eu le mariage pour tous qui a été
une avancé en termes de droit mais qui a
été aussi catastrophique à un certain
niveau parce que ça a libéré la parole
homophobe et transphobe et que c'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles il y a un
gros travail de sensibilisation et
d'accompagnement à faire
et donc on mène aussi des actions de
prévention de sensibilisation comme
d'autres associations
pour faire évoluer les l'état d'esprit
les mentalités
parmi ces associations SOS Homophobie
les bénévoles viennent en aide aux
personnes rejetées discriminées et
violentées en 2021 près de 1500
témoignages ont été recueillis sur toute
la France 15% des cas de violence sont
commises par des proches voici quelques
exemples
Sami nous écrit ne sachant que faire mon
petit copain de 21 ans a fait son coming
out ce samedi cela se passe très mal et
il est retenu prisonnier chez ses
parents son père lui crie dessus il est
insulté
Salomé annonce à ses parents qu'elle est
lesbienne et qu'elle souhaite rejoindre
sa compagne à Barcelone dans quelques
semaines le père de Salomé connaît
l'adresse de sa petite amie en Espagne
et menace de la tuer quel qu'en soit les
conséquences
on a des parents qui insultent leurs
enfants qui ne leur parlent plus qui les
enferment qui les empêchent de sortir on
a des gamins qui sont en souffrance de
tirailler entre l'amour des parents
ce qu'ils doivent à leurs parents et
puis ce que leurs parents leur font
vivre de violent ne pas accepter qu'ils
sont être à ce point fermé voilà c'est
très compliqué pour eux
je crois que pour un parent c'est
toujours compliqué on peut être très
tolérant face à l'homosexualité mais
chez les autres c'est pas grave quand ça
arrive à la maison c'est plus compliqué
là on doit se poser des questions
il va pas vivre comme tout le monde
peut-être on n'aura pas de petits
enfants alors que là c'est plus un sujet
aujourd'hui la filiation c'est plus un
problème les parents doivent cheminer
aussi en même temps que leur enfant
c'est pas bien dans la cage qui te sert
trop
fort quand un enfant se fait un coming
out c'est parce qu'il sent la nécessité
d'informer ses parents entre autres
parce qu'il se rend compte qu'ils sont
en train de se projeter sur des
situations qui n'arriveront pas
[Musique]
donc cette nécessité de dire aux parents
elle te l'a arrêté de rêver là je serais
heureux mais je serai pas heureux avec
un gars mais avec une fille
si tu veux partir quitter un foyer sa
famille et parfois la seule solution
pour survivre pour exister c'est ce qu'a
fait Lola hébergé par son père dans une
commune à proximité de Lille cette jeune
transe a rejoint le refuge il y a 6 mois
une étape nécessaire c'est très
compliqué
du mal à prendre des rendez-vous et
autres c'est très compliqué depuis que
je refuse elle m'a beaucoup beaucoup
mieux et bien heureusement ma tête est
plus libre on va dire et ça aide surtout
à sentir bien mentalement et pour une
fois on se peut se poser tranquillement
et puis faire sa vie à avancer
correctement sans être gêné ou sans être
embêté on va dire là je sais que je
signe un contrat bientôt donc je vais
travailler bientôt grâce à tout ce qui
est du refuge et autres
et je sais que je prends mon appartement
mon petit chez moi tranquillement on se
dit enfin et c'est un nouveau départ
surtout le refuge ce sont aussi des
soirées entre personnes accueillies et
bénévoles des moments de partage de
convivialité pas seulement un
hébergement ou une aide administrative
les bénévoles va accompagner plus
l'accompagnement culturel le truc tu
vois humain
anciennement accueilli par le refuge
Rémi vole désormais de ses propres ailes
il est même impliqué dans la vie
associative après avoir été hébergé et
aidé il a décidé de s'engager notamment
en rejoignant l'équipe qui coordonne la
Praille de l'île
rendez-vous aujourd'hui avec
l'organisateur Franck Chiron la
communication est essentielle
pour les plus jeunes leur dire que on
continue à se battre pour qu'on garde
nos droits voilà c'est très important
les enceintes génération dont la
génération je pense de nos
grands-parents manquait d'informations
sur le côté LGBT comme eux ils sont plus
de la génération du sida où on parlait
beaucoup de la communauté LGBT très
négativement oui à partir du moment où
on accepte soi-même ce sera beaucoup
plus facile d'être accepté
au quotidien mais regarde ça attends non
mais ça c'est une [__] et puis que ça
nous revient en face à partir du moment
où ça déclenche une interrogation déjà
on parle et si on parle ça veut dire que
des gens on est dans la réflexion
tu veux me refaire un bisou c'est ça tu
vas faire un bisou Rémi travaille
aujourd'hui dans le secteur de la
communication et de l'événementiel comme
ce défilé de mode organisait au sein de
la prestigieuse Chambre de Commerce de
Lille un univers où il se sent épanoui
tu vas passer par le pire et là j'ai le
meilleur bon la ville va pas toujours si
simple
mais là ça grâce à ces événements comme
ça qu'on me font
prendre confiance en moi aussi à
m'accepter je relève le défi tu
m'apprends à marcher à défiler pas trop
bien je le fais l'année prochaine il y a
aucune cause de perdu que quand on se
bat on arrive toujours à s'en sortir
mais bon il faut la vie n'est pas simple
si la vie était simple vous le saurez
mais que bah voilà c'est un exemple moi
j'en connais d'autres de garçons et de
filles qui se sont battus et qui sont
encore aujourd'hui plus fort que jamais
[Musique]
nous espoir pour les personnes
accueillies par le refuge elles sont
près de 700 et des chaque année même si
rien ne remplace l'amour d'une famille
des proches des structures sauve des
vies et elle se bat au quotidien pour
obtenir plus de moyens
[Musique]